[Music]
it's just a movie
you see Natalie lots not a fairytale it
was like I still get that full one look
in the mirror doll when though Julia
Roberts
everyday I swipe my cotton don't love me
Natalie saying that romantic comedies
are about all those maybes allows that
the terrible pop songs I think people
would have an easier time seeing you if
you were a little more open you're in
your mercy sir this is an emergency room
this is at williams-sonoma boy downtown
it looks like somebody's what a beauty
filter across New York City and I won
one what's your emergency
someone's broken into my apartment and
they've taken everything and replace it
all with much nicer stuff so your
emergency is that your apartments too
big and you have every show you could
ever want
yeah exactly that's what I yeah you go
crazy
I hit my head really hard and I woke up
in this alternate universe and now I
have a gay sidekick who's setting
gay-rights back like 100 years of love
working the legs and guys look at me in
the eyes so quite beguiling aren't you
are you feeling what I'm feeling
No
[Music]
okay boots what's the update I have to
get a man to fall in love with it I'm
Josh
he's such a beautiful me
good morning beautiful last night was
amazing I think we actually did anything
and just cut to the next morning well
just get that here okay last night was
amazing
Natalie I love
[Music]